welcome to Table Talk where each week I
pack insights from Christian theology
and spirituality that help you become a
thoughtful contemplative and downright
great human being my name is Brett
pastor at the table and today I want to
talk to you about that moment you know
that that moment that that little moment
between the thing happening in your
reaction to the thing you know that that
moment when your co-worker says the
thing that annoys the heck out of you at
that moment where your child is
screaming in public with that shrill
little voice that says hey look at me I
have terrible parents that moment right
or that moment when you lose your job
right or your spouse calls it quits or
the project that you devoted a year of
your life to comes crashing down when
the frustration reaches the boiling
point you know that in that moment you
see sometimes that moment it's a big
moment but truth be told more often it's
a small one in fact we have dozens of
these each day I've been coaching my son
Dax the soccer team and this past season
we'll just say it was a rough one and so
at one point about halfway through the
season he and I were just talking about
his team and all of a sudden he says hey
dad maybe if you had a plan we could win
a game can you see the moment emerging
there it is and I'm sad to say I missed
it because I looked at him and I said
well bro
maybe if you'd score a goal my plan
would work a little better yes I'm a
terrible person
all right so but there it is right
there's the moment right between the
thing happening and my reaction to this
thing right it's a little space but that
little space is everything because it's
there that I can realize this moment is
not actually about them it's not about
soccer or my son or my coaching prowess
or the lack thereof right or in your
circumstances about my spouse or the job
or the
it's not about that that what this
moment is is an opening a space where I
am encountering some powerful emotions
and I have a decision to make as Pema
Chodron says she says in that moment I
have to ask the question am I going to
make peace peace with myself peace with
this person peace with this situation or
I would add peace with God or am I going
into war maybe just a little war right
with myself with them but war
nonetheless that that's the question and
those are the moments so today notice
those moments pay attention to them and
oh by the way if you ever wondering what
on earth is the point of spiritual
practices like wha why on earth would I
sit in silent prayer
why would I fast not eating food are you
a crazy person
why would I journal about my feelings
each day because it's about those
moments noticing them paying attention
to them because at first you only catch
yourself after the moment has passed
after the damage has been done but later
you catch yourself in the moment in fact
that can be life-changing
well that's all for today if you enjoyed
this video please like share comment and
subscribe to my youtube channel by
searching Brett Tilford grace and peace